what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story in
this one luffy and adult dragon momo
finally confront kaido again the moment
we've all been waiting for so make sure
to stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
seeing these one-piece reviews and want
to keep them coming channel the pirate
king within and smash that like button
with no mercy remember that smashing is
pirate king energy and passing is orochi
energy so the choice is yours if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my big and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
admirals and much much more linked to
that is in the description and now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all this chapter is called
twin dragons which as we know must be
referring to kaido and momo whose adult
dragon form is identical to kaido's
except for the color of course last
chapter we also got a glimpse at the
center of the color spread which we get
to see here in its full glory absolutely
love it a different yonko gets each
corner but goldie rogers in the back
behind luffy who's in the center which
is telling since luffy of course will
become the new pirate king no matter how
long it takes we also get to see the
former warlords including my boy mihawk
and characters who've passed like
whitebeard and ace i don't usually talk
about the spreads this much but there is
so much to talk about here it's amazing
and i would love to have a giant version
of this in my house but back to the
chapter which starts with luffy yelling
at momo to fly already although momo had
quite the intimidating presence at first
we shouldn't be surprised that he
reverts to being fearful despite his
outward appearance we were told this
would be the case by shinobu the
physical change had no impact we were
led to believe on his actual mind which
is still that of a kid so that will no
doubt lead to some hilarious situations
where an intimidating looking adult or
dragon will act in childish ways not
only will this be funny but it's better
for the story because momo is still
forced to overcome his fears rather than
flying past them with the power of a
magical fruit thus we get this funny
situation where the giant dragon is
scared of heights and talks about how
his body is frozen most likely because
he's so frightened momo even said that
raising his head alone in this form is
daunting because he's so big that line
definitely made me laugh luffy obviously
doesn't care calling him a wimp and
wonders how he's still scared of heights
if he's a grown-up but as i explained
he's not actually a grown-up except in
appearance of course momo does have his
pride and tells luffy to keep his
insolent thoughts to himself and that
samurai feared nothing that's what i'm
talking about love that line samurai
fear nothing we continue to get a back
and forth of luffy trying to get momo to
fly as fast as possible so he can meet
up with kaido again and momo telling him
to slow down and give him a second i
don't think momo will suddenly start
acting like a complete adult by the end
of this arc in humorous ways he'll
probably keep revealing that he's still
mentally a kid but there's no doubt that
from this point on he'll mentally grow
into his body in the important ways
he'll overcome his fear enough to help
luffy reach kaido and he'll get a second
chance to confront kaido in a more manly
way than when kaido spared him all those
years ago and that's only the beginning
and when i say overcome his fear i don't
mean that he'll become fearless just
that he won't be paralyzed by the fear
and will be able to act through it we
then jump to yamato vs kaido a fight
that's been going on longer than i
expected it to each time we catch up
with them it feels like kaido is more
and more in the lead because we
obviously know the strongest creature
will eventually win in a prolonged
battle however yamato doesn't stop
impressing us at first i was like what
is going on when i saw her figure
shatter but it appears to have been a
kind of mirror slash ice clone this got
me off guard because we definitely don't
see something like this in one piece as
much as we do in naruto kaido thinks
this means she's going on the defensive
but then yamato pops out of the
surroundings and lands a very satisfying
hit that brings the yonko down to the
ground not for long but still very
impressive that yamato is doing things
like this after all these chapters not
to take away from yamato's amazing
efforts but we also can't really assume
kaido is going all out as he keeps
trying to convince his child that she
should be on his side you think he'd
give up by now after all these years but
he keeps trying to convince her saying
she acts like she's from wano but can't
escape the truth of her blood she's
kaido's child and the samurai will never
accept her as one of them so even though
they're in the middle of a war and kaido
should probably be finishing her off as
soon as possible here it sounds like
he's being protective in his own messed
up way it's like he doesn't want yamato
to be disappointed and feel left out
because the others won't ever truly
accept her while he will yamato then
tells him to shut up and hits him in the
face saying what's that got to do with
anything for her she's doing the right
thing and it doesn't necessarily matter
if the samurai accept her as a samurai
or not as i said before for a yonko
kaido is being and has been very lenient
towards yamato still a bad dad no doubt
but most military leaders would not have
put up with a constantly defying
presence for two whole decades and after
all this time he's still trying to
reason with yamato in the middle of a
giant war kaido tries to break yamato's
will by saying she's alone which is why
she's been crawling through addicts and
desperately trying to escape wano but
yamato says she's not alone she has and
had friends and she thinks of ace kaido
brings up the samurai from last chapter
including zoro's dad i'm guessing and
says that everyone that shows her
compassion ends up dead now he's trying
to make her feel alone and guilty we get
a flashback where she overheard that
someone was executed because he was
feeding the oni princess and the mental
games might really be getting to yamato
since kaido is able to land a powerful
hit that brings yamato down and at this
point it really feels like kaido starts
projecting aka trying to force his own
view of his experiences onto yamato's
life he's hitting yamato while saying
their acts of kindness were just lies
the truth is they were all afraid of you
after all you could easily use your
power to impose your will on others
you're the offspring of an oni relying
on the friendship of humans is beneath
you we see kaido's monstrous figure and
i don't think he's ever looked so
demented clearly he is a tortured
individual and like i said i feel like
what he's saying reveals more about
himself and how he feels than it does
about yamato in one piece we don't know
much about oni but a quick search lets
us know that in japanese folklore and
oni is a type of demonic creature often
of giant size great strength and fearful
appearance interestingly enough they are
said to be cruel and malicious but they
can be converted to buddhism in other
words even these demonic creatures can
turn over a new leaf if oni really is a
bonafide race in one piece it explains
why kaido and yamato have horns even in
their human forms and this could be an
unofficial translation thing so take it
with a grain of salt but kaido does say
she's the offspring of an oni singular
rather than of multiple oni so she could
even have a human mom from wano who
knows she might be half half in which
case that adds another layer to her
character and struggle either way i look
forward to oda fleshing out the
importance of oni in one piece as we
move forward and we'll hopefully learn
more about their history for instance
does kaido hate the idea of relying on
humans because historically humans
betrayed the oni whatever the case kaido
is clearly a man in pain and tortured by
something then we jump to luffy riding
dragon momo as they make their way
through the sky and towards the island
hilariously momo overcame his fear in
part by closing his eyes so he can't see
how high up they are this leads to such
a funny moment where the giant dragon
breaks through the ceiling of the live
floor and everyone sees luffy riding on
top of a kaido-like dragon how's that
for a morale boost not only is luffy
alive and well he also recruited a
kaido-sized dragon for their team too
that could not have worked out better
momo just keeps crashing through
ceilings and so eventually they'll have
to get to the roof we even get to pass
big mom law and kid i just love to see
the reactions of all the characters big
mom's reaction is hilarious as she
wonders if that's luffy riding kaido and
wonders what's happening luffy keeps
telling momo to open his eyes which is
not surprising when you keep torpedoing
through walls face first what a great
way to shake up the energy in the castle
some people think kaido is wreaking
havoc while others notice that this one
is a different color so there are two
dragons in play kaido for his part
thinks big mom is to blame when he hears
all the damage having no idea that he's
about to see his dragon twin it's funny
how in the distance behind yamato you
suddenly just see momo panting going the
wrong way i really enjoy the humor in
this chapter i gotta say finally they
spot kaido and decide to crash land
there and momo's eyes are finally open
props to him luffy enters gear fourth
snake man my favorite gear form so far
as yamato goes to hit kaido luffy makes
it a combo and they send the yonko
flying back the luffy and yamato reunion
is great and full props to yamato who
not only kept kaido busy but seems
pretty fine even now i half expected her
to be down by the time luffy finally got
there but she's still smiling and able
to land hits truly amazing and oni must
be one of the races with the most
endurance because kaido bounces back in
his dragon form seemingly not a scratch
on him this dude has been fighting
non-stop for a good while with a lot of
top tier opponents and looks completely
fine as if he's just getting warmed up
it's not surprising that even though
he's apparently lost in the past he's
never been killed but we finally see the
two dragons face to face as kaido
wonders how is luffy breathing and who
is this dragon luffy proclaims once
again echoing last time where he did get
overpowered that it doesn't matter what
kaido does luffy is not going to die he
says i'm the man who'll be king of the
pirates then momo has his chance at an
epic reintroduction at first he stutters
but then gets into it and says my name
is kozuki momonosuke i am the man who
will become shogun of wano as he stares
down kaido's dragon form it's a far cry
from his crying self as kaido spared him
20 years ago and i'm really proud to see
how far he's come of course yamato's
eyes brighten up as she recognizes its
momo and i can't wait to see her react
to momo's odin looking adult form she
may well fall in love since they are
pretty much the same physical age right
now and she is odin's biggest fan kaido
laughs saying you're the brat how
unexpected this world doesn't need
another dragon so he clearly remembers
momonosuke and yeah it's clear that he
did not expect him to come back in this
way we're told that i quote head-to-head
clash of dragons and that is it for this
chapter there will be a break next week
but this was definitely an epic chapter
to go on break with luffy vs kaido for
the final time is here we even got to
see a punch thrown we'll get to see how
the two dragon dynamic goes visually
luffy looks like a boss here there are
two dragons present but only one luffy
and he's even riding on top of one of
them as if it's his tamed pet obviously
the actual circumstances are a bit more
complicated but i'm pointing out what
people would visually be seeing and this
is how legends start imagine if luffy
wins how the people who saw him riding a
dragon will speak of him luffy the
dragon tamer so much greatness here as
always let me know what your favorite
moment of the chapter was who was your
mvp this time around i'm torn between
momo and yamato momo faced his fears by
closing his eyes hilariously destroyed
kaido's castle and helped luffy shock
everyone before finally facing kaido and
staring him down as he made his
reintroduction on the other hand yamato
not only kept kaido busy all this time
she was still getting good hits on him
and was still going strong when luffy
came that oni endurance really appears
to be next level also let me know what
you're most looking forward to seeing
next if you did enjoy this video you
know what to do channel the paraking
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember that smashing is
piraking energy and passing is orochi
energy so the choice is yours if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates that's just
the way it works and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my big and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko warlords admirals and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself alpha
sigma and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand on top all clans ingrata
but they have the al-jatal hinokami in
water the toasted chi the spike corey
mcgowan dylan isadore spidey life
tennelle tungsten tarkis baked buddhist
cody hebert and monkey d quilly and our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired raven angel
cruz brethuen de aura very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia ted no
ted fatboy games and soul ride slice and
dice thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon.com anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get a name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patronly discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you are interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer and whichever way
to support us you will get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you